um the White House is on a top secret
mission to save President Biden's
reelection chances axios reports today
that it is called essentially operation
don't let him trip Democrats are
reportedly very concerned that the
president could take a bad fall before
the November election and that that
would set off um a difficult
conversation as we head into election
season and perhaps it could be very
embarrassing so the president's team is
taking active measures to ensure that
ites doesn't happen quote with a
physical therapist Biden's been doing
exercises to improve his balance he has
been wearing tennis shoes more often to
avoid slipping and using the short
stairs on Air Force One and it looks
like this plan is already in motion
President Biden using those small steps
today going down Air Force One and it
looked like he had to catch himself at
that moment that you just saw that is
the don't trip strategy in in motion
here it's a far cry from what the media
and Democrats have been publicly saying
about the president's Health watch this
it is hard for us to keep up with this
President uh who is constantly
constantly working every day to get
things done Joe Biden is agile is
capable incredibly sharp incredibly
probing incredible command he's doing
more than showing up for work and
functioning he's he's doing the job that
we put him in there for as he says every
day watch me and he puts many of us to
shame with his energy you know what his
age and wisdom has has been able to do
it's been able to
transformative pieces of legislation
he's younger than I am so I he's a kid
to me as
well so uh Janine I mean if if you work
for the president I don't know what else
you're supposed to do they're trying to
make sure that he doesn't have that fall
that is discussed that could be I mean
we all you hold your breath when you
watch him go down the stairs yeah we all
hold hold our breath and I counted the
number of stumbles and falls in the last
couple years there were 11 of them and
that's with an advanced team that's with
people you know making those shorter
steps and putting him in a position
where you know he's not going to have a
problem look 77% of Americans think that
Joe Biden is too old to be affected for
four more years and yet the team around
him is saying you know they're lying you
know Martha it's true they're lying
they're saying you know like swall well
he puts us to shame with his energy no
he doesn't he doesn't show up before 10
he's got to have rehab for a few hours
he's got vacations at the beach he
doesn't come out until 10:00 he goes on
ice cream runs he takes a nap he doesn't
go out to dinners when he's in foreign
countries I mean he doesn't even have
time for the job you know and you got to
wonder why does he want this job so
badly when he's humiliated like that
what do you think other world leaders
think of this man and you know at some
point you have to say maybe it's time
for me to Exit the stage I'm
embarrassing myself but all but forget
all that let's assume that they he
doesn't enough PT and he doesn't have
any more stumbles all he has to do is
open his mouth it's still over them Greg
you hold your breath around uh Joe Biden
I hold my breath around Eric
swell isn't it weird though isn't it
funny how Joe and his polls are in
perfect SE symmetry they're both falling
figuratively and literally they're
perfectly parallel and talk about a low
bar that they're setting for him it's
not like let's get Joe to tackle the
issues let's prep him to take on Trump
maybe create a system or a plan to fight
crime or deal with immigration or the
economy no it's make sure he doesn't
fall flat on his face and he's not even
drinking which is you know that could
explain it everything about maintaining
the facade the Joe Biden facade and it
is one begins with the word don't don't
let him speak too long don't let him
walk or ride a bike don't let him wander
off don't let him eat gassy foods don't
let him sniff children's hair or
passionately kiss visitors teenage
daughters but they can't expect him to
do anything thing it's all don't don't
don't I mean he really is like a caged
bird and he's not running the country we
are aware of that and he doesn't mind
this role because he was born to be a
figurehead he was born to be a hood
ornament just wear the wear the the
bomber jacket in the aviator sunglasses
and make sure I get a hot meal so um
Jessica you know it always makes me
wonder when I see these stories who's
leaking this um and is there a movement
to try to nudge him in the direction of
saying I'm going to I'm going to step
aside there's a very public movement
that's happening obviously a congressman
Dean Phillips ended up being the face of
it but you do see it and the numbers
about whether people want him to run
again and whether they think that he's
up to the job and the Democratic numbers
are lower than the Republican numbers on
that but they still exist um and it's a
conversation I think the White House is
taking it on more than they were before
which I think is important and you can
see a shift in the way President Biden
is talking about the age issue um
talking about like judge me on my
accomplishments I know that I'm old it
used to be that he wouldn't even kind of
acknowledge that but I got to say so
part of the the core of the axios piece
was about the sneakers that he'd
switched to sneakers and then our very
own peter juicy is on Fox and Friends
this morning wearing the same sneakers
that Joe Biden wore and he said everyone
on Capitol Hill from age 36 to 80 is
wearing these sneakers we worried about
Peter Ducey falling down too well but
Peter duy Peter duy also when they were
on their latest overseas trip was
talking about Biden's schedule remember
when Biden said I got you know I'm going
to go take a nap or it's late and Peter
said that he was working to the we hours
of the night he said he's held a
complete schedule and our perception
around the world by the way is up since
Biden came into the into the presidency
based on what I based on what other
world leaders and people in other
countries think of America but you said
okay you don't need to watch him let's
just hear what comes out of his mouth M
and I put together some of Trump's
latest cognitive Beauties from the last
10 days he said you need an ID to buy
bread has anyone shown ID to get
Wonderbread lately he said that he ran
against Obama in 2016 he ran against
Hillary Clinton he warned that Biden
will get us into World War II which I'm
pretty sure we already fought and won
and yesterday he confused Jeb Bush and
George W bush and said that Jeb got us
involved in the Middle East and then of
course there are his authoritarian po
post on true social calling for the
chair of the Joint Chiefs of Staff to be
executed and saying that he's going to
investigate media companies that he
doesn't like and can you imagine if
Biden said you know what I'm going to
look into that Fox News they don't seem
to like me over there this may be the
choice that people have Trump versus
Biden um laid bear here Jesse at least
Trump can say LL Cool J Jessica are
youor ID to BU Biden has to stay upright
and Trump has to stay out of prison
think about how ridiculous that is that
is the most corrupt and low expectation
situation where Joe Biden has to not
fall flat on his face to have a shot at
reelection and he promised us he would
get us back to normal but all he's
worried about is making himself look
normal he's not worried about inflation
it's not like oh if I could just get
inflation down and rates down and crime
down and illegal immigration down then
I'd have a shot it's I just need to stay
on my two feet then I can get back into
the White house he's forgotten about us
and his people have forgotten about us
too because while they should be
worrying about health care and access to
Affordable they're worried about the
commanderin-chief not falling over a
sandbag they're trying to make sure he
has the right shoes they're trying to
lower the back to the stairs to get back
into Air Force One those aren't the
things that they should be concerned
about they're working for us they should
be concerned with us they should not be
concerned with the prop of a president
being propped up and Greg hit it this
whole presidency has been choreographed
from the fake set to these little fake
press conferences to the lack of access
this guy is a walking standin and he
can't even stand and he's about this
close to falling down again and that's
how scared they are I would just say
today he was standing upright on the
picket line with the Auto Workers right
and tomorrow Trump will be showing
showing up at a non-union plan in
Michigan he was not invited by the union
to come and speak yeah okay well I
bought bread with an ID the other day
standing up standing up is a pretty low
bar and I had beer too that's why hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else